the House Oversight Committee this
morning is investigating the Trump
administration's travel practices the
administration was already under fire
for travel by Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price and Treasury
secretary Steve Newton now CBS News has
learned the EPA paid tens of thousands
of dollars for administrator Scott
Pruitt to take non commercial flights
Julianna Goldman broke the story this
week and has new details from Washington
Julianna good morning good morning well
former government officials and ethics
watchdogs say the non commercial air
travel by Trump administration officials
is unprecedented documents obtained by
CBS News show the Environmental
Protection Agency and its administrator
Scott Pruitt have spent more than 58,000
dollars in non commercial travel costs
since February on July 27th EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt flew on a
private plane from his hometown of Tulsa
to an event in Guymon Oklahoma then he
boarded the same 12 seat Learjet and
flew to Oklahoma City records obtained
by CBS News show that in total he spent
83 minutes in the air costing taxpayers
more than 14 thousand dollars the EPA
says the flight was chartered through
the Interior Department as part of an
interagency program there were no
commercial flights available and the
drive was 5 hours each way process rule
of law and cooperative federalism that's
going to be the heart of how we do
business at the EPA in total Pruett has
spent nearly $60,000 on non commercial
travel since February according to
information obtained by CBS News and
documents provided to Senator Sheldon
Whitehouse who requested the details
last month in June tax payers shelled
out $36,000 when Pruitt flew on an Air
Force jet from Cincinnati to New York
where he caught a flight to Italy for an
international summit in August Pruitt
took a $5,700 air charter between Denver
and Durango Colorado in both cases the
EPA says commercial travel would have
prevented Pruett from attending official
events on Wednesday President Trump was
asked to address travel costs of other
members of his cabinet including
Treasury secretary Steve Newton's use of
military and government planes and 400
thousand dollars wrapped up by his HHS
Secretary Tom price inspectors general
at the EPA the Treasury Department and
the Department of Health and Human
Services are now all looking into air
travel habits the EPA says its ethics
office approved all of Pruitt's
non-commercial travel and Charlie a
spokesperson says Pruitt has taken one
private charter and three government
flights and there have been no
additional non commercial flights
Julianna thanks